There are two ways to use music as the
foreground itself,
an object of attention or as the
background that contextualizes the rest
of your world.
Instrumental music often falls into that
latter category.
Humble and unassuming.
Most people overlook this kind of music
in favor of music that has a direct
message.
In fact,
instrumental music almost never comes up
on the charts and the same way that
songs,
it just doesn't capture people's
attention in the same way and I think
that's because many people misunderstand
the role of instrumental music.
We often listen to instrumentals as we
would a song and that's a mistake.
When we listened to songs,
our mind is automatically parsing it for
meaning for understanding of the
songwriters message.
And if you do that with an instrumental
piece,
you'll be sorely disappointed because in
an instrumental meaning and message
aren't explicit.
That's left up to you and I want to
examine this difference through the song
entitled five by Kendrick Lamar because
there's a significant portion of the
song that is an instrumental before
Kendrick comes into rap,
and this perfectly illustrates what is
gained and lost when explicit meaning is
given.
In the beginning of this piece,
we hear a jazz camp
on his own.
We may call to mind a friend,
a sunny day,
the smell of espresso,
a hipster coffee shop.
We are free to give meaning,
but this vanishes when Kendrick comes
into rap because he begins to tell a
story.
I got 100 no,
my dad's name in the grab bag in the
trunk.
So even though we gained something,
when Kendrick comes in a clever story,
different viewpoints,
we also lose something.
Whatever meeting to song could have
helped to us after it's intended.
Meaning is explicitly told.
Now of course there's always room for
some interpretation songs,
but our interpretation has been limited.
You're no longer in a coffee shop.
You're in Kendrick's car.
It's not a sunny day.
It's raining God on the engine.
This fed off in the brain,
and this is how Kendrick Lamar can help
us understand instrumentals through what
we lose when he starts rapping,
we lose focus on our own world,
which is replaced with his,
and there's nothing wrong with that.
I myself love getting lost in Kendrick's
vivid world.
But if you understand this difference
between songs and instrumentals,
you may find the instrumentals can fill
a gap.
That song's camp songs for most people
are too distracting for studying,
having a conversation with someone or
reading a book because they say too
much.
But instrumentals perfectly.
Lay a mood without trudy.
So assuming you don't already tried
turning on an instrumental for a change
and see how it affects you differently,
construct your own meaning and message.
Hey,
thanks for watching this video as a
help.
To those of you who aren't big
instrumental heads,
I'm going to include a bunch of links.
So the description that may help you
find an artist you like,
and those of you who are ready,
listen to instrumentals,
comment below with your favorite
instrumentals that others might not have
heard of before.
Who are you listening to?